Traduttore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Confesso che, quando ho saputo
il titolo di questo incontro,
mi è venuto un colpo.
Perché è dalla notte dei tempi
che le menti più illuminate
cercano di dare una risposta
a questa domanda.
E quindi io, che non sono -
non so niente di filosofia,
non conosco il punto di vista
delle neuroscienze,
non sono un’artista,
non sono una creativa,
non sapevo che cosa
avrei potuto raccontarvi.
Poi, mi sono resa conto
che l'unica soluzione che avevo
era quella di raccontare
la mia esperienza,
e quindi di quello che, credo,
dentro di me abbia mosso la bellezza.
E così, vi parlerò
della mia interpretazione,
che è un’interpretazione
“fatta con i piedi”,
nata grazie a quello
che ho raccolto dalla terra
camminandoci dentro,
un passo dopo l'altro,
in decenni di vita passati a scalare
le montagne in giro per il mondo.
Vorrei cominciare con una storia
che si svolge nello Xinjiang,
l’antico Turkestan orientale.
È una regione immensa della Cina
che è abitata da un minestrone di etnie:
Uiguri, Tagiki, Kirghisi - e anche Cinesi.
È il mese di giugno del 1994,
e da giorni stiamo camminando
dentro un’isola di vuoto
che si allunga a fianco del Taklamakan,
il famoso deserto,
da cui non si torna indietro.
E ci stiamo muovendo
come un'antica carovaniera
perché stiamo seguendo
il passo dei cammelli,
le “navi del deserto”.
I nostri animali sono divisi
in gruppi di quattro o cinque, legati.
Sono legati uno all'altro
da un anello al naso
e sulla schiena trasportano
i bidoni con il nostro materiale.
A condurli ci sono
una decina di cammellieri.
Sono Uiguri, Tagiki e Kirghisi,
sono lingue, etnie diverse.
E quello che li accomuna è la terra,
è quella terra primordiale.
Noi siamo in 14,
e quello che ci lega
è l'oggetto del nostro desiderio:
il K2.
Che vogliamo conoscere
non dalla sua faccia famosa,
quella della conquista italiana del ’54,
ma dal suo lato nascosto
e poco conosciuto,
che è il versante Nord.
Da qualche parte
avevamo visto una fotografia,
e quello che ci aveva lasciati senza fiato
era la bellezza della sua forma
da quel versante.
Che è un triangolo perfetto.
E ancora di più ci aveva colpiti
la linea perfetta dello spigolo
che dalla base lo risale
ininterrotto fino alla cima,
a 8611 metri.
E così eravamo lì che,
a un passo dopo l'altro,
ci stavamo addentrando
dentro questo mondo sconosciuto,
con il desiderio di andare a toccare,
a sfiorare la bellezza
di quella linea perfetta
che nessuno aveva mai salito.
Eravamo lì,
siamo arrivati a fine giugno
al fronte del ghiacciaio.
Mancano ancora 25 chilometri
per arrivare ai piedi della montagna,
però i cammelli devono fermarsi lì,
quindi scaricano il materiale
e se ne tornano ai villaggi.
Verranno a riprenderci fra 50 giorni,
e fino a quel momento
noi saremo completamente soli.
Senza telefono, senza collegamenti.
E senza sapere se il Mondo,
fuori, esiste ancora.
Siamo lì.
Per terra ci sono
le impronte dei cammelli.
Davanti, abbiamo la forma perfetta del K2.
E tutto intorno,
nient'altro che il silenzio.
In altre parole, siamo in mezzo al Mondo
come era prima e come sarà dopo di noi,
dopo l'Uomo.
Sono insieme a Romano.
A differenza sua, che era
già stato lì tre anni prima,
per me è la prima esperienza su un “8000”.
Ho un bagaglio di esperienza
maturato in tanti anni
di scalate sulle Alpi,
però questa sarà un'esperienza
completamente nuova.
E cercherò di affrontarla
un passo per volta, fin dove ci riuscirò.
Quindi, tornando lì,
siamo completamente soli.
Siamo soli, allo sbaraglio,
in una libertà che è senza confini.
Soli e responsabili di vivere.
Adesso ci aspetteranno
tutti i 25 chilometri,
dovremo trasportare tutto il materiale
fino ai piedi della montagna
e da lì iniziare la salita.
E sarà un viaggio nuovo
perché la strada
ce la dovremo inventare noi,
ce la dovremo inventare da soli.
È un viaggio che ti inghiotte,
ti mette in disordine la vita.
Perché lì le certezze,
i riferimenti che abbiamo a casa
non valgono niente,
anzi ti illudono pericolosamente
di poter controllare la situazione,
ma in realtà lì è la Natura che decide.
E quindi, adesso,
non solo dovremo affrontare
il pericolo “oggettivo” della salita,
ma dovremo affrontare anche
il rischio di sentirci persi.
E allora, per non affogare nell'angoscia,
l'unica soluzione è quella
di cambiare i passi della danza.
E allora, per prima cosa,
bisogna avere poche regole condivise,
e quindi autosufficienza
fisica e psicologica,
pazienza, umiltà,
approccio consapevole al pericolo.
E, prima di tutto, la certezza
che, lì, o si perde
o si vince tutti insieme.
Poi, in secondo luogo,
bisogna accettare di vivere l'Ignoto.
L’ignoto sia fuori ma anche dentro di noi.
Per quanto possa sembrare assurdo,
bisogna cercare
di affidarsi alla montagna.
Il 31 luglio siamo pronti
per tentare la cima.
Come cordata d’avanscoperta
siamo in tre: Romano, Filippo e io.
E quelli che stiamo facendo
sono i primi passi umani
che tracciano quella linea
che è intatta da sempre.
Facciamo un ultimo bivacco a 7800 metri,
partiamo in un'alba freddissima
e alle 14:00 oltrepassiamo i 8400 metri,
ancora convinti che ci fosse
il collegamento fra lo spigolo e la cima.
A 8450 scopriamo che il passaggio non c'è,
e che la nostra via, dalla bellezza pura,
finisce lì, su una torre
che è completamente staccata dalla parete.
La mia reazione, a differenza
dei miei due compagni,
non è stata molto signorile.
Ricordo che, mentre scendevamo
verso il campo base,
Filippo mi ripeteva una frase,
una frase di Oscar Wilde:
“Quando gli dei ci vogliono punire,
ascoltano le nostre preghiere”.
Mi ci è voluto parecchio tempo
per mandare giù il rospo,
perché non capivo perché
la nostra via fosse finita lì.
Perché mancavano solo 150 metri alla cima,
stavamo bene, eravamo [lì] presto,
le condizioni del tempo
e della parete erano buone.
Quindi non capivo perché.
E poi, pian piano, l'ho capito.
Ho capito perché gli dei
non avevano ascoltato le mie preghiere.
Perché avevano voluto
che imparassi, da subito,
ad accettare il fallimento
senza scoraggiarmi.
E, difatti, è da quella cima mancata
che è cominciato il cammino
che ha portato me e Romano
a salire in cima a tutti i 14 “8000”.
Ma non è stato
per un desiderio di rivalsa,
ma piuttosto per una voglia
di continuare a metterci in gioco,
a esplorare sempre
con il desiderio di andare,
di cercare di toccare quella bellezza.
Perché la bellezza
non smette mai di chiamarci.
E quando ne siamo colpiti
non abbiamo paura
a voltare le spalle alle sicurezze
per cercare di raggiungerla,
magari anche a fatica, un passo per volta.
Anzi, è meglio: la paura c'è!
La paura di affrontare l'ignoto,
la paura di perderci.
Ma la accettiamo
come una compagna di viaggio
e, anzi, a dire il vero, è anche utile,
perché è lei che ci fa
mantenere desta l'attenzione,
che ci permette anche di trovare
le soluzioni più economiche
ai problemi che ci si presentano
lungo il percorso.
A una condizione, però:
che quando saremo lontani dalle sicurezze,
dovremo imparare a sospendere i giudizi
e accettare di vivere
un futuro incerto, sconosciuto.
Perché solo in questa maniera
riusciremo ad aprirci all'ascolto,
e in questa maniera
a trovare nuovi equilibri.
Non solo fuori, ma anche dentro di noi.
C'è anche la possibilità
dell'insuccesso, del fallimento, certo.
Ma a quel punto torneremo indietro
con uno sguardo diverso,
perché avremo intravisto
la possibilità di nuovi percorsi.
E soprattutto torneremo indietro
consapevoli che l'imprevedibile esiste.
E che la vita, la realtà,
è fatta di opposti.
Perché così come c'è il giorno e la notte,
il sole e la pioggia,
i successi, i fallimenti,
allo stesso modo
c’è il coraggio e la paura,
la forza e la fragilità.
Ma gli opposti sono come
le due facce di una medaglia,
che solo quando le metti
insieme la compongono
e ti restituiscono
la bellezza della medaglia.
E allo stesso modo,
anche noi siamo la sintesi
di tutti i nostri dritti
e i nostri rovesci.
E a quel punto,
il fallimento ti apparirà
semplicemente per quello che è,
ossia una tappa del nostro percorso.
Ustià!
La cima, la cima del K2 poi è arrivata.
È arrivata 12 anni dopo,
al terzo tentativo,
un K2 salito e disceso da me e Romano,
in completa solitudine, in 5 giorni.
Perché le altre spedizioni pensavano
che non ci fossero le condizioni,
eccetera eccetera.
Siamo arrivati su il 26 Luglio del 2006.
Eravamo io e Romano soli,
su tutta la montagna,
e l'abbiamo chiamato
il nostro “K in 2”.
Ed eravamo lì,
non abbiamo sventolato bandierine,
non abbiamo alzato le braccia
in segno di trionfo.
Semplicemente, ce ne stiamo stati lì,
accovacciati a terra a guardarci intorno.
E con lo sguardo potevamo
abbracciare l'orizzonte.
E soprattutto è stato un momento,
un attimo di grande chiarezza.
Una sensazione pacificante.
Perché eravamo immersi
nella consolante vastità dell'Universo.
E non la guardavamo: ne eravamo parte.
E a quel punto,
l'unica cosa che ci è venuta spontanea
è stato semplicemente un “Grazie”.
E- spero di riuscire
a leggervi due righe, due,
che ho scritto in una sera
in un campo base.
"Adesso è sera,
e credo di non avere mai visto
una notte così piena di stelle.
Dal nero profondo, un crepitio di luci
ci sta piovendo addosso:
grandi, piccole, brillanti, tenui.
Alcune lanciano lame di luce,
altre pulsano pacate.
E sullo sfondo, un tappeto
fitto di puntini luccicanti,
come se una mano gigantesca
li avesse seminati a manciate.
E noi due qua sotto,
immersi nella grazia di questa notte,
dove insieme danzano Terra,
Luna, Sole e Stelle.
Che bello sarebbe,
se la bellezza fosse contagiosa.”
Grazie.
(Applausi)